welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and it seems like
the Sharks are already circling on the
Joker movie and it looks like we're
gonna get the PC Brigade out in full
force trying to take down this movie
this comes in the wake of Robbie Colin
from the UK newspaper The Telegraph
asking Wacken Phoenix Union interview if
he thinks the Joker might perversely end
up inspiring exactly the kinds of people
it's about with potentially tragic
results to me this is just a pretty
stupid question and I would say more
that the Joker is influenced by
real-world events rather than the other
way around
it's the classic of the media trying to
blame things like video games and movies
on real-world violence when several
studies have shown that there's not
really any correlation Phoenix rightly
so got up and walked out of the
interview asking Colin why he would ask
such a question and he reportedly had to
be calmed down by Warner Brothers staff
before returning to finish the rest of
the interview now you can probably tell
I completely agree with him I think it's
pretty clear and has been for the past
couple of weeks that since joke has
started getting positive reviews and
even Oscar buzz that a lot of media
outlets have been trying to trash the
movie and bring it down because they
don't really like the message that's
been portrayed in it even though most of
them probably haven't seen it anyway a
couple of weeks ago the film got labeled
as problematic by several work reviewers
and to me more than anything it just
kind of highlights the hypocrisy that
exists in movie reporting today so
basically the film is being bombarded
with bad reviews focused on its subject
matter rather than the execution behind
it if you go on Rotten Tomatoes you'll
see some of the following the movie is
indeed terrifying but that's because
it's horrific Lee unintentionally
insightful of how such men are viewed
both from without and within three out
of ten that's by Andrea Thompson from
the young folks Emma Stefanski from
Thrillist says the movie isn't badly
made or even ugly to look at but there's
a mean smug little heart at the centre
of it that at best irresponsibly frames
a familiar male power fantasy as a
revolutionary act Leah Greenblatt from
Entertainment Weekly says a movie with
the message this one hammers home
again and again feels too volatile and
frankly too scary
to separate from the real world violence
committed by young men like Joaquin
Phoenix's Arthur Fleck in America almost
every day like they're admitting that
the movie is really well made but they
don't like the fact that the film's
challenging all the thing that its
centers around now these reviews kind of
scream to me the sheer contradictions
and double standards that we have in
online media these days and how
depending on if you switch things like
gender or race for a film it can either
be labeled as problematic or empowering
for example the recent movie hustlers
starring Jennifer Lopez is basically
about strippers drugging and robbing men
and this is labeled as empowering and
something that's great for women however
the movie stars cardi B who earlier this
year admitted that before becoming a
rapper
she had drugged and robbed men yet
nothing bad is being said about this and
the movie is not being called
problematic even though it happened in
real life it's the equivalent of Kevin
Spacey starring in a film about sexual
harassment I can't believe that there's
no controversy surrounding this at all
we simply just don't have a balance and
you can already see that Joker is
getting lobbied up and already blamed
due to the way the outlets are reporting
on it we didn't see this kind of
criticism Lobby dad the female gangster
film the kitchen when that film - could
also inspire evil now hustlers is a good
movie and I'm sure Joker is - or at
least it remains to be seen I don't have
a problem with movies betraying violence
the difference is that ones being blamed
for inspiring evil whereas the other one
won't be now you can make a great film
on any subject matter again I have
nothing against violent movies whether
they've got male or females or people of
any rate in the role but there's a huge
double standard where something is
viewed as being negative whilst others
are being viewed as positive the main
thing behind this is that Phoenix is
just doing his job and to say that he
could be inspiring evil is completely
misguided and pretty insulting rather
than focusing on the fact that Phoenix
lost 50 pounds for the role or is
getting a lot of Oscar buzz instead
questions like this are given airtime
because that will drive clicks like put
yourself in Phoenix's shoes how do you
even answer a question like that
that is two ways either you say yes it
will end
by evil and the newspapers go off and
write their shock and outrage headlines
or you say no and they go off and write
their shock and outrage headlines about
how you're not taking responsibility
it's a lose-lose situation and I'm
surprised that Phoenix even came back to
answer the questions the question has
been put in place so that the
journalists can twist things rather than
to objectively view the film in the way
that it's supposed to be we saw this
earlier in the week when Rambo
last blood got review bombed by several
critics including high G end who
labelled the film as too violent and in
our word that I can't say or get
demonetised anyway critics need to stop
putting their personal beliefs and
opinions into films and then judging
them purely for not having them and
instead objectively view the work think
of a world where we can't have movies
like Joker or Rambo and you're pretty
much left with everything being
inoffensive and therefore not
challenging I think that the beauty of
Joker will be in the fact that it isn't
PC it asks the tough questions and it
betrays a dark side of morality that I'm
sure many will walk away from thinking I
don't want to become that you could
argue that Breaking Bad inspired many
people to become like Walter White but
I'm sure in reality that it probably put
most people off living a life of crime
and the majority of the world would have
just viewed it as entertainment if he
walked out of the interview it's
probably because he's read the rest of
the Telegraph and he knows it's a pretty
trash paper and sorry but Joaquin
Phoenix cannot be taken responsible for
what his viewers of the phone do people
are their own people and it's their
responsibility and it's constant blame
culture that shifts things away from
personal ownership it's really failing
to address the real problems and thus
we're moving in the constant circle
Joker whether you think it's problematic
or not still needs to be seen because
it's taking risks it's asking us to look
at our society and condemn this kind of
behavior rather than celebrate it if we
don't have films like Joker then we're
just gonna end up with nothing but
movies about people just going through
their day to day life afraid of open
their mouths and as a culture will
become pretty new it and who wants to
live in that world not me
so I'm storming out of this video I'm
off
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on this and if you think Joker
is getting bombarded with bad reviews
because the media have an agenda or not
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and if you want to see something a
little more lighthearted then make sure
you check out my breakdown of every time
that Mysterio was in the background of a
scene in Spiderman bar from home I go
over all of the things that you missed
in the movie so it's definitely worth
checking out if you want to know more if
you want to come talk to me on Twitter
about movies TV shows games comic books
and Joker then make sure you follow me
at Definition whitey it's the best way
to get in touch with me and is the
perfect place to suggest new videos and
content so hopefully I see you over
there after this also just wanna let you
know that we're giving away a free copy
of spider-man far from home on blu-ray
and all you have to do to be in with the
chance of winning is to like this video
make sure that you subscribe to the
channel and leave your thoughts on this
story in the comment section below
the winner will be chosen at random on
October the 15th then the blue arrow be
shipped out from then to ever get
surprise so best of luck to everyone who
takes part this is a channel for people
who are super into superheroes so if
that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this I've been definition
you've been the best and I'll see you
next time take care
[Music]
you